there are a bunch of hidden features in
the ps5 that sony hasn't really shouted
about just yet so we're going to run you
through nine of them
let's go profiles have been revamped on
ps5
on the overview page you get a quick
look at everything going on with that
person's ps5 profile
including a look at the new accolades if
you're familiar with the endorsement
system in overwatch
these might look familiar they're there
to encourage a positive playstation
community and you can give one accolade
per match
when playing online the ps5 also finally
shows you how many hours you've played a
certain game for
and unlike the switch which waits a few
days before it gives you that figure
it shows you right away this is also
retroactive for ps4 games
profiles also have a tab that collates
every screenshot or video you've ever
shared via your linked social networks
so if you want to revisit that play of
the game that really popped off it's
right there for you
if you're fed up of having to invert
controls or change difficulty settings
each time you boot up a game
the ps5 now has a system wide sole for
that in settings
save data and game app settings game
presets
you can choose your preferred difficulty
level whether you play in performance
mode or resolution mode
whether you invert your camera or not
and your subtitle preference
right now this only works with games
that support this feature but it's very
cool nonetheless
you might notice that the dual sense
controller has a nice grip
look closely and you'll see that it's
actually made up of tiny playstation
symbols
but that's not the only place you can
see them look on the inside of the
console's faceplates
if you tap the playstation button to
bring up the control center then tap the
options button you'll be able to
customize what appears
on the bar meaning you can quickly pin
things like accessibility
broadcast network and music options if
you want to reserve your internal ps5
storage for ps5 games
you can set the console to always put
your ps4 games
on extended storage if this isn't
enabled
you can't choose where a game gets
installed when you start installing it
you also can't install ps5 games or move
them onto an external hard drive
just fyi you can change your privacy
options way more easily on the ps5 as
there are now
a number of various privacy profiles
that limit what you share publicly
there's a privacy profile that opens
everything up meaning pretty much
everything you do can be visible to
others
privacy profiles that keep your activity
friend focused
and there's one that hides everything
you're up to you can now favorite screen
grabs or video clips which makes them
show up
in a different tab when browsing the
media gallery screen grabs when trophies
are earned look
different with a new border that shows
the name of the trophy and its rarity
by default the ps5 captures a 14 or 15
second long video each time you earn a
trophy which you may want to turn off if
you're interested in saving space
the ps5 game library has seen some
changes to ease navigation
for starters you can now quickly filter
by platform so you can see all your ps3
4 or 5 games in one spot it's also now
much easier to see where you got a
particular game from
whether it's the playstation store ps
plus or ps now
you can also see at a glance where you
have each game installed which is
particularly useful if you use
external storage a lot you can also use
the game library to quickly access demos
or ps4 versions of ps5 games you have
attached to your account
the playstation 5 has a few more
accessibility options than the
playstation 4.
when you first boot up the console the
screen reader is on by default in its
setup
speech speed normal you can also set up
the console to convert voice chat to
text
and even to read your written chat
messages to other players when using the
ps5 keyboard to input text
tap r1 to autocomplete you can also hit
l3
to use emojis
so there we are 9 hidden things you
didn't know your playstation 5 could do
for more on sony's brand new console
keep it gamespot
[Music]
you